you get a good chance to see all the
different uniforms you've got the
grenadiers on the left there with their
buttons equally spaced then in the
middle from slight to the right of our
picture got the scots guards with
thistles of their collar and buttons
with
and the queen has come onto the balcony
with the duke of kent
[Applause]
there's quite a lot of stuff in the way
of the balcony for this particular
platinum jubilee it will make for the
public it very difficult to see the
balcony
and
when one compares with
the coronation and previous
jubilees there
will be a difference this year and all
of that front of the palace is a
building site now
and so they have specially constructed a
safe route for the queen to come from
her rooms
in order to be in position as
the duke returns a salute to
those passing by
troops are still coming but the queen
won't really see them because from that
balcony the queen victoria memorial put
up
in 1913 blocks the view
but she can hear the crowd's reaction no
doubt
and she has the chance to take the
salute from her household cavalry
[Music]
[Music]
the queen is
colonel in chief of the arsenal cavalry
regiment
made up as we've seen of the lifeguards
and the blues and royals
lifeguards of the senior regiment in the
british army
formed to look after king charles ii
when he was
in exile during the commonwealth